go beyond
when we think of iconic anime moments we
think of stuff like yo that was so high
oh that was so sad oh damn that was so
shocking but when you watch enough anime
you start to notice familiar patterns in
the premise the stories and definitely
the moments that define them a big
climactic fight a plot to Wish You Don't
See coming a sad death of a character
there are so many great moments like
these that are extremely powerful in
their own ways but isn't something you
generally haven't seen before yes Demon
Slayer episode 18 is absolutely hyper so
are a lot of other beautifully animated
high intensity fight scenes but
sometimes there's a moment in an anime
that just sticks out for me for
different reasons some may even say that
they hit different I said it I said the
thing these are moments that might not
be the most hype most iconic most talked
about or even the most memorable but for
one reason or another they've just
refused to leave my mind so I've
compiled a short list of giggax random
anime moments that live rent free in my
mind in no particular order or theme yes
I'm only making this like a nerdout
about [__] I don't get to talk about
enough obviously there's going to be
spoilers so I'll make sure to show what
I'm going to talk about before I start
each segment but if you're anything like
me I have this awful habit of
discovering shows and movies I want to
watch by watching out of context scenes
I've recommended on YouTube even if they
are full of spoilers I know I know okay
so hey maybe you're as broken as I am
but without further Ado let's get to it
but before I start my first pick a quick
word from today's sponsor guys you know
what time it is it's boxy time box is a
premium Japanese stack boxer works with
businesses all over Japan to bring you
authentic snacks from their country you
get a new theme of great treats every
month sent straight to your door look at
this box now this box can hold a lot of
treats I tell you as you guys know
summer is coming up which is why this
month's theme is Dory summer
that means green summer I'm not hungry
Josie yes Junior's rainy season in Japan
which is when we get the best Greenery
and fruits a man could ask for and all
the snacks in here reflect just that all
right first we've got some shiromiso
senbei I need something Savory first
before I get to the suite so let me give
this a shot
smells so delectable
oh do these lunch when you got boxy holy
crap this is hitting the sport
and oh my God I just saw this if you
don't know these Sable cookies are
golden this one's the pear Sable cookie
I've never had the pear flavors before
so
the perfect Cookie doesn't exist
oh wait oh nice and soft and Rich mmm
God damn so if you want to try some
awesome Japanese snacks today and also
help support my channel click the link
in the description to get some boxy for
yourself or a friend you can also use
code gig up to get 15 off your first
Boxer you purchase thank you very much
the foxy for sponsoring me today back to
the video give me more give me more
thank you
music performances the climatic moment
in any music anime that separates the
men from the boys the woman from the
girls the beeps from the boobs I'm not
even a big music guy but great
performances can be some of my personal
favorite moments in all of anime there
is a wave of emotion you can get that is
different from a hype fight scene or a
sad dramatic scene Harry K on your line
April Angel Beats there are a lot of
iconic music scenes in anime but to me
no performance has made me feel such a
journey of emotions as much as kids on a
slope episode 7.
thank you
when you hear that the director and
composer of Cowboy Bebop are teaming up
again to work on a music drama revolving
around Jazz you get excited and this is
coming from someone who doesn't know the
first thing about jazz except that one
of the main tracks used in the show is
the Jazz classic monin which is aptly
named because every time I hear that
sexy jazz beat it got me feeling like
wait wait no wrong clip wrong clip uh
yeah that'll do it's Japan it's the
1960s and you have two best friends who
are about one seductive look away from
kissing the homies good night and
shouting though JoJo but at this point
in the series they are having a little
bit of a Lover's tip they aren't talking
to each other their music group has
broken up and the drummer has gone and
joined another band right before the big
school Festival music performance but oh
no something's gone wrong before they're
about to get on stage the setup was
predictable we knew what was coming but
that didn't detract from the magic we
were about to see
[Music]
the school is treated to the purest
unplanned jam session between two
musicians you could ask for doing their
own rendition of the sound of music's my
favorite thing to Snow White Someday My
Prince Will Come for four glorious
minutes their musicians become their
voice actors not a single line of
dialogue is dotted between them but you
understand everything they are saying to
each other through the language of music
and like the audience I was absolutely
mesmerized
I'll be honest I'm kind of illiterate
when it comes to trying to break down to
describe music so all I can say is that
the beeps and the boobs fired up neurons
in my brain so hard it might as well
have turned the serotonin being released
into goddamn crack yeah this scene was
so good this jobs are so sexy it got me
more bricked up than all edgy fan
service anime I've watched combined and
just when I thought I couldn't get more
bricked up just when I thought they
couldn't peek any harder they pulled
this out
[Music]
in my mind too many anime feel the need
to talk over their performances to tell
you exactly what the characters are
thinking to tell you exactly what you
should be feeling and the beauty of this
scene is that they just let the music do
the talking from the perfectly accurate
animation to the Callback to previous
songs so the character developments you
see on stage to the emotions this made
me feel this scene is a [__]
Masterpiece are my all-time favorite
music performance I've ever seen in an
anime
one
voice acting without voice sighting we'd
be watching a silent film and great
voice acting can Elevate the most
emotional scenes from an anime into
something even more spectacular
[Music]
love you or we can break it there have
been so many amazing moments of voice
acting that I've seen in an anime I
can't even come close to listing them
all from the serious to the sad hyped to
emotional to performances that are
downright spellbinding like
Restless vagrant you idiot we'll just
steal off the miners now clearly the art
of voice acting peaked here but that's a
video game amazing voice acting features
and some of the most iconic scenes in
all of anime so it's incredible that the
first thing that comes to mind when I
think of a single voice acting scene
that dropped my jaw to the floor is not
from this or this but from a slightly
above average Studio trigger show that
no one bloody remembers when
Supernatural battles become commonplace
what does that mean he's an edgy tryhard
fuckboy think of every overplay Trope
every Bland isakai protagonist thinks
makes them badass having a special power
possessing some super secret knowledge
that only they know that makes them
better than everyone basically
everything that's said from Eminence in
the shadow tries to be without a shred
of self-awareness that's this guy here
and hakuto has had enough
oh so you
know you are dare think of everything
you've ever wanted to scream and shout
at every edgy too cool for school
teenager you've met and that's where
hakuto is because for two unstopping
uncut unfiltered minutes she just
unloads foreign
[Music]
she continues for another goddamn minute
while upping the intensity it is
downright captivating
foreign
opportunity and she took it Mom's
spaghetti stories from the staff members
came out about how she nailed this on
one take and left everyone in the
recording booth in silence and honestly
I can't blame them because I think I'd
realize Sue that I just witnessed one of
the best voice acting moments in history
damn Restless vagrant got some
competition
I love anime fans but God damn some of
y'all got that Tick-Tock brain if
there's not a character getting punched
or something exploding every five
minutes I gotta start playing some
Subway Surfer at the bottom of the
screen to make sure you guys are paying
attention but when done right nothing is
more engrossing to me than a good
dialogue scene Aaron confronting
Reinhard yangwen Lee meeting Reinhard
pretty much anything from monogatry
these are moments of nothing but
characters talking that had me glued
onto the screen more than any Michael
Bay Mega minus explosion ever could but
the one dialogue scene I always come
back to is the banquet of Kings from
Fate Zero episode 11.
one
all right pause now I know this is
lesser scene and more an entire bloody
episode but that's how gripping it is
I've watched this subbed I've watched
this dubbed I've watched this goddamn
raw and I'm still hooked from minute one
to minute 20. and no it's not because I
get another chance to explain fate
all right so let me explain fate what is
the card we've got a battle royale to
the death going on where there can only
be one Victor out of seven teams that
comprise of seven Majors who are paired
up with a hero either from Legend or
real world history
probably even [__] do this again now
at this point we are well into this
battle royale people have died battles
have already been fought every team is
at each other's throats then out of
nowhere one of the heroes bust through
the enemy's stronghold turns up at that
doorstep faces off with them and he's
like fans are going to the pub and
grabbing a pint die in the life of a
true brexit gazer
that's right no swords no fights what
proceeds to happen is a whole episode of
three of the heroes sitting around in a
circle drinking and
talking
just a bitter banter this is a prime
example of what happens when you put a
bunch of interesting Larger than Life
characters in the room together and let
them carry a scene with dialogue alone
because while at the beginning it's nice
just to see these characters interacting
without the pretense of a fight it
really starts to kick off when the topic
of what it means to be a true king comes
up I have every intention of plundering
your abundance to our house until it's
been laid bare so get ready
that is hardly fitting of how a true
king should behave
Gilgamesh Ryder Alexander the Great and
saber King Arthur three legendary Kings
from their respective time periods with
three different types of kingship one of
selfishness one of ambition and one of
Duty each of them presenting their case
while tearing the others down and it is
enthralling because while there are no
punches being thrown I would argue that
this is one of the most compelling
fights in all of Fate Zero it's a battle
of ideologies using their words as their
weapons not a single line is wasted not
a single useless sentence is uttered
this is what Twitter users see in their
Mind's Eye and what I love is just how
Bloody convincing they actually are you
don't start believing they're kings
because the plot told us they were you
can see it you start believing of them
yourselves with the words that they say
cause God damn it is delivered in an
inspiring way for the people in its
fictional universe and in real life as
well you who became a ruler only to
satisfy your endless greed a king
without greed is even worse than a
figurehead
saber you said you would martyr yourself
for your ideals in life you must have
been something akin to the purest of all
the saints but who can truly admire the
rough and thorny path that a martyr must
follow in life
who actually dreams of such an ending
a king
must be greedier than any other you must
laugh more loudly and rage for much
longer and embody The Very extreme of
all things good and evil my man's out
here making a case for being a
tyrannical leader and I'm somehow being
convinced because I think the most
amazing thing about this scene is that
objectively they are all right and they
are all wrong in their own way it should
be impossible for anyone to actually win
this fight yet through sheer Charisma
and Giga chat energy a winner does
emerge through his words and actions
Ryder is able to shake saber's ideology
to her core his words cut deeper than
any sword ever could and if that wasn't
enough he ends things off with a
demonstration that shows her what his
kingship means and he uses his Noble
Phantasm essentially his all don't worry
about it a move you should really not be
revealing to your enemies willy-nilly
just to prove a Goddamn point oh it was
so worth it this was the most epic
conclusion for one of the most gripping
dialogue scenes I've experienced from an
anime no matter who would eventually go
on to win the Holy Grail War ultimately
Ryder won over our hearts in the scene
which was oh so on point for this
legendary character my bond with them is
my greatest treasure my path to kingship
the ultimate Noble Panther awesome that
I possess
[Applause]
oh my God
his Noble Phantasm is the friends he
made along the way
all right that was a really long segment
so you know what anime dancers there's
been a lot of iconic anime dancers
throughout the years if you're in my
generation she could dance if you're a
goddamn Zoomer Jujutsu Kyson ZD if
you're on Tick Tock JoJo's torture dance
if you're on grinder but out of
everything there's been one dance I
swear a broken YouTube's replay button
watching shirobako episode 16. alright
so you gotta promise me promise me
you're not gonna leave this video to
find this clip and replay it 10 times
after I finish playing it or I promise
like pinky promise I trust you because
otherwise I'm gonna tell your mom I
swear I'm gonna tell her you're a little
liar liar pants on fire
play the clip
[Music]
that's it that's the scene
you still here
when people talk about Shonen battle
series we say stuff like damn that was
such a banger fight scene or damn I
can't believe this guy just called
Jujitsu kaisun mid oh damn is that a
Dragon Ball fan of more than 10 IQ but
beyond the fights the souls and the hype
nothing has quite sold me on a
long-running Shonen faster than the 20
minutes of Chaos in chainsaw man episode
9 and makima's ritual
am I doing a bit of a cop-out by picking
a moment from one of the most hyped
recent anime yes did I want to talk
about this so I have something to
clickbait this video with in the
thumbnail maybe but this stands out to
me as how to do a turning point in your
story
please don't kill me with joking tensei
fans more than any of the Chainsaw
massacring fight scenes more than any of
the boob touching makima Caboose
sniffing action this showcased that a
battle Shonen could do more than just
drop a cool action scene on you because
what stood out to me the most is that
out of nowhere the show just turns into
a full-on survival horror as makima
looks at light laughs in his face and
goes heart attack what are you into
little baby [__] this is how you send a
message what gets me about this entire
sequence it's just the sheer emotional
Whiplash after everything that's been
built up we had seven episodes
establishing your usual Shonen Affair
then in just one episode you realize oh
the people I thought were safe are
definitely not these villains are way
more terrifying than I ever gave them
credit for then the series doesn't even
give us five minutes to process that
before throwing a fat una reverse card
in our face you feel a sense of eerie
dread for the bad guys it does a better
job than 90 of horror anime have ever
done the direction the music her
unsettlingly calm demeanor the fact that
these people can sense that they're
about to die of violent death before
they do is a [__] horrifying thought
and after everything is said and done
you're like wait should I be more
terrified of the good guys or the bad
guys here this was just such a
brilliantly directed scene from start to
finish that went beyond the great action
you expect from a Shonen and if that was
just a taste of the Mayhem to come
chainsaw man season 2 cannot arrive soon
enough until then I have to live with
the scraps I've got to find out what's
really going on behind the Terra boner
markama has given us as the true horror
antagonist herself
[Music]
flowers of evil was an anime that looked
like this look at this dude this was a
show that took some
creative decisions with this Asylum
Aesthetics and when it aired in 2013 the
internet destroyed it meme after meme
screenshot after screenshot it got
clowned on Into Obscurity but now that
time has passed I think people are
starting to realize that we didn't
really give it a fair chance sure
sometimes the visuals look so bloody
ridiculous but it looks more like a
comedy from a thriller but behind all
that there is a truly amazing story
being told here one that explores the
darkest parts of our human emotions that
we bury behind the public mask we wear
and there's one scene that has always
stuck out to me in this series that
everyone had already written off flowers
of Evil episode 7. takao kaska starts
the series as someone who believes he is
different to everyone because that's the
person he wants to be pretending to
enjoy obscure poetry being an all-around
edgy [__] he's not like other boys there
are two wolves inside of him the winner
complicated girl
[Music]
Nakamura sees him in a moment of
weakness she knows what perverse and
sick desires lie beneath the surface he
presents she torments him wears him down
and blackmails HIM Tears into him for
days until you see all of his fake
ideals and the facade he wears crumble
into nothing this scene is that Breaking
Point
foreign
proceed to completely wreck the
classroom in an explosion of catharsis
as he Embraces who he really is with a
sheer visceral display of emotions it is
almost chilling watching this manic
destruction of their classroom as every
layer of his old Persona is peeled off
one by one
this was the moment where I fully
understood the Creative Vision that
semi-realistic uncanny look on top of
the eerie unnerving music left me with a
symphony of conflicting emotions few
anime are able to make me feel it was
equal parts and settling as it was
beautiful that final shot for the circle
of chaos they created is an image that's
etched into my mind just them laying
there two messed up teenagers in a room
matching how [__] up things are in
their head this was then I understood
this was why the show looked like this
this was what akunohana was meant to be
there was something special here and a
sad more people didn't give this a
chance for a season 2 to be made
hentai
foreign
there are many moments in anime that get
me emotional enough to get the
Waterworks running sad parts that pull
up the heartstring until there are no
emotions left to ring out but sometimes
I watch a scene that makes me tear up
even if there's nothing sad happening on
screen and one of those moments is the
running scene from episode 2 of a place
further than the universe
[Music]
this scene hits me every time I re-watch
it Bar None and I still don't fully
understand why because I'm the only one
I've talked to that has had this kind of
emotional response to this moment but if
I had to quantify it if I could pick a
scene so perfectly captures the Carefree
moments you remember from your younger
years this is it it is Pure Freedom
[Music]
we all have a cherished memory tucked
away somewhere of some dumb crap you got
up to as a kid that one random thing you
and your mate did on that summer holiday
getting up to some stupid Antics on that
one trip you took with your siblings or
family we didn't realize how precious
those moments would be or how fondly
we'd look back on them when we were
older and what gets me is this
overwhelming feeling that we're seeing
one of these Precious Memories being
made right in front of us three girls
going out of their comfort zone to go on
an adventure and just having the time of
their lives doing dumb [__] I will never
not adore this moment maybe even more so
than some of the more serious scenes in
the series it might not be the most hype
the most sad or the most dramatic moment
you can find in anime but it gets me
emotional in a way few are ever able to
I love this show
[Music]
and that was everything I had time to
talk about today I didn't even get
through a tenth of everything I could
have talked about but I don't want this
video to be an hour so who knows if you
guys like this enough maybe I'll do some
more of these types of videos if you
didn't already know I'm going to be
touring Europe with trash taste in
September this year a lot of tickets
have already sold out but we have a few
venues with some availability so if
you're in the area get your tickets now
while they're still available I'll leave
a link in the description for all the
available venues left and of course
thank you to the patrons this month
Alpha Sigma author Curtis Eckstein basil
dysfunctional degenerate flabberwocky
ivido lovados
moussaka12315 Payne Patchett Pony Stark
waltergeist VT and everyone else my
patreon for helping to support me for
this month and making this video
possible anyway though that's it from me
for today I've been gig up and I'll see
you all next time